when you think of ringed planets well
you probably assume there's only one of
them in our solar system Saturn
but what if I told you that there are
three other planets similar to Saturn
yeah it's true Jupiter Uranus and
Neptune all have their own sets of rings
that most people don't know about them
because they're much thinner and pretty
much invisible from Earth
we only learned about them when Voyager
1 and Voyager 2 flew past them in the
1970s and 80s
some scientists even think that Earth
had rings at some point in its existence
four and a half billion years ago when a
planet the size of Mars smashed into our
young rock it ejected so much debris
that it likely briefly formed a small
ring around Earth